de janvier à septembre le calendrier
politique français sera rythmée par
plusieurs scrutins pas moins de trois
élections nationales prévues en 2017 et
le 23 avril les électeurs se rendront
aux urnes pour désigner leur nouveau
président de la république
si françois hollande a fait le choix de
ne pas briguer un nouveau mandat les
prétendants sont nombreux
sont d'ores et déjà en compétition le
candidat des républicains françois
fillon jean luc mélenchon sous les
couleurs de son mouvement la france
insoumise emmanuel macron pour le
mouvement aux marches ou encore marine
le pen pour le front national
pour le parti socialiste il faudra
attendre le résultat de la primaire
second tour le 29 janvier sept candidats
à départager et parmi eux le député
blinois benoît hamon l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation ministre de l'économie
sociale et solidaire est aujourd'hui
présenté comme un rival sérieux à manuel
valls et arnaud montebourg
à noter que pour le scrutin quelques
7530 bureaux de vote seront ouverts dans
l'hexagone un site internet a été lancé
pour trouver celui situé le plus près de
chez soi
aussitôt la présidentielle terminé il
faudra passer à la désignation des
députés l'assemblée sortante est composé
de 313 députés de la majorité
présidentielle 232 la droite
parlementaire onze d'europe écologie les
verts 9 du front de gauche et deux du
front national dans les yvelines la
gauche ne détient que 2 des 12
circonscriptions deux circonscriptions
qu'il sera difficile de conserver au
regard du contexte national
pourtant l'enjeu est de taille pour le
ps qui a déjà perdu l'intégralité de ses
représentants lors des dernières
élections au conseil départemental
les français ne se rendront pas
directement aux urnes mais leurs
représentants au sénat vont aussi changé
pour 170 d'entre eux et notamment pour
ceux de l'île de france
un renouvellement par moitié peau une
chambre actuellement acquise à la droite
la droite dispose en cette fin de
mandature de 4 des 6 sièges du
département sport culture enseignement
supérieur action sociale quelles seront
les compétences de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines demain composé
de douze communes depuis un an le
nouveau territoire n'a pas encore défini
l'intégralité de ses missions il ne
reste que jusqu'à décembre pour les élus
afin de se mettre d'accord
passé cette date la loi prévoit tout
simplement que l'intégralité des
pouvoirs soit exercée par
l'agglomération aux dépens des villes
aujourd'hui élus de la majorité et de
l'opposition ne parviennent toujours pas
à s'entendre et puis sur un plan
international de
17 sera aussi l'année des 60 ans du
traité de rome le 25 mars l'europe
célèbrera un texte qui dans son
préambule aspirent à établir une union
sans cesse plus étroite entre les
peuples européens
six décennies plus tard l'union
européenne et pourtant secoué par une
importante crise identitaire et
politique